peering out and tracking the sea for
migrants juliette wolford sees herself
as part of a new home front defending
the coast
would you like to tell me why you're
here video cameras are also part of the
armory
she and other activists are angry at the
constant arrival of boats
i would like to see a proper secure
process
if these people are running from war
i think then we need to help them
but there are a lot of the migrants that
are not running from war
everyone here including juliet is
shocked by this tragedy but many agree
with what she's saying
but others are not so sure
a short distance away on another cliff
sits k marsh from channel rescue
her volunteer group checks the weather
and alerts the coast guard to any boats
in distress
the tragedy in the channel was an
accident waiting to happen there are a
lot of people that do really care and
they do want to promote this welcoming
in dover they're just frightened because
it is a very controversial issue we need
to see these people as human beings who
are fleeing death destruction poverty
and war
they may be two women a few miles apart
but their reactions to what they've been
witnessing over the last few years could
not be more different
but they do agree on one thing the
government's handling of this crisis has
been disastrous
and more will die at sea without a
solution
the chaotic arrival of migrants on the
beaches along the kent coastline is
likely to become an even more divisive
problem in the months to come in this
community it's already a toxic and
polarizing issue
and the optics of all this for the
government could well become a political
liability it's all extremely damaging
for a party that campaigned on taking
back control and sovereignty
at the heart of all this are of course
the migrants nearly 26 000 arriving in
the last year
some stay at this former military
barracks in foxton
ushang ibrahimi is typical of the asylum
seekers we meet an iranian kurd who
converted to christianity he tells me he
faced death threats and had to flee
it was dangerous for my life something
is coming dangerous to my life
you were scared to stay in iran yes it
was like this
it's clear to many here that the home
office is failing to deal with the
numbers claiming sanctuary
this is a problem entirely of the home
office's own making there is enough
accommodation the problem is is that
asylum claims not being processed
quickly enough by the home office they
should take six months they're taking 18
months minimum
in the seaside towns on the front line
of this crisis people are fed up with
the government's response
the home secretary may say the asylum
system is broken but what they want to
know here is why hasn't she fixed it
alex rossi sky news dover